- [Gary] Anything that
allows you to be 100% close
to the end consumer is always the best.
(gentle music)
- My content, if you
could look at it one day,
it's more tactical, I like
to give them more tools.
Less motivation, more tools.
- Yep, the details.
- But somehow it's much
easier to push sex, comedy...
- People want escapism.
People wanna escape their life.
They don't wanna make it better.
- But you think The content is
a way of escaping their life?
Or you think that you're
really educating them?
- I think I'm tricky, and I
don't know this to be true,
this is my hypothesis, I
don't want anything from them
and I think there's something
very real about that.
You know, there is no funnel.
It's a big deal.
I think that's why I'm winning.
Unlike almost every other business
whether tactical or
motivational, somehow, someway
it's leading to a course, to a mastermind,
to something that, you know
and so I'm giving so purely
that I think subconsciously
people understand that,
and I think I'm entertaining
at some level, but...
- But we have to be a
little bit of entertainment.
- I don't think one
has to be, I mean look,
I think there's a lot of
people who are educators
and things of that nature, that
are not entertaining at all.
I think you see the ones
that are entertaining.
You don't see the ones
who are doing 27 million
selling the course quietly,
nobody knows who they are,
you know?
- Mm-hmm.
- So I think the entertaining
or the sizzle is in the face
and people think but like,
I mean there's hundreds
of thousands of people
that make more money than
me on internet marketing,
because all they wanna do is the money
and you don't even know who they are,
and they have 47,000 landing pages,
and they have 400,000
different marketing campaigns,
you know?
All depends on what one wants.
- There you go.
- You know?
♪ Yeah, uh-huh ♪
It all depends on what one wants.
For me, I wanna be the entrepreneur
that gave back to the most entrepreneurs,
that's what I want, I really do.
(upbeat pulsing music)
♪ Yeah ♪
- [Man] You're really
into TikTok aren't you?
- I'm really--
- Are you excited
with what's happening, and how quickly--
- I'm always excited when
a new platform comes along
that has 100s of millions of users
and you can have no following, post once
and get a million views,
yeah, that's very rare.
That was 2011 Facebook, you know,
this is very rare, and
I'm just fascinated,
people's ability--
(man speaks faintly)
Yes, but people's ability to say no.
- [Man] What frightens people,
what scares people of TikTok?
- Judgment of other people.
They don't wanna make a TikTok video
'cause they're worried
about their friends,
and business friends,
and associates saying,
"That's for kids and it's stupid."
Mm-hmm.
And the biggest thing, the
biggest reason TikTok matters
to somebody who sells steel,
and to 60-year-old C-suite
executives in a B2B business
is not that TikTok even
at scale, if it got older,
is necessarily gonna be a platform
for that person to do business.
It's that humans are reacting
to certain styles of content,
and it's important for you
to pick up on those nuances.
It would be no different
than when hip-hop came along.
Everybody who only believed
that rock and roll was important
they said no to hip-hop, they
said that's not real music.
And then it became the music.
And so that's always what
happens in popular culture.
The way we story tell on TikTok
is going to matter in 10 years.
Nowadays, the Internet
is the distribution.
To your point, Leonardo, you know,
distribution used to be very expensive.
If you wanted to start an
actual television network
you had to shoot a satellite into space.
If you wanted to be a newspaper
you had to buy a printing
press and have distribution.
Because the Internet, for
all of us in this room,
is free, the reality is that everybody
has the potential to be
in the media business.
On a personal brand level,
on a talking about your favorite subject.
If you wanna be the most
important media outlet
around football in the country of Mexico,
properly executing on top of Instagram,
properly executing on top of YouTube,
starting a podcast with no cost,
gives you the potential, if
you're a good storyteller,
to be in the game within
two, three years, it's crazy.
How are you my friend?
- Okay.
(photographer speaking
in foreign language)
- Hi, Gary, how are you?
- How are you?
It is highly likely, highly likely,
that the breakthrough, or the advancement,
or the growth that you're looking for,
comes at the expense of you understanding
that you're actually a media company,
and not what else you do.
I believe that everybody will
realize over the next decade
that almost everything in our
society is being commoditized,
except the ability to communicate.
That when you think about what
you do, the product you sell,
and your ability to communicate it,
is fundamentally what's left.
The Internet will become the wholesaler,
the distributor, the middle.
(ring tone chiming)
Hey guys, sorry to interrupt your video,
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community,
212-931-5731, hit me up with a text.
(slow electronic music)
What up, sir, how are you?
- I feel like I know you.
- Thank you, man.
- I'm gonna ask you a question.
I'm in the B2B business,
I'm doing like you're doing,
like, the whole thing,
strategy, cats, everything.
Do you still think we
should still be doing
like you know like trying
to keep the content
on landing pages and stuff,
and so people leave their
email and everything?
Or do you think we should
just push everything?
- I think a mix is always
right, but I think the old
you know, content through
a Google search strategy
is more vulnerable than
it was eight years ago.
Your strategy that you just laid out
is a Google search strategy.
And I believe that we've
become more of a content,
social network-first place.
- So you feel like if I invest
a ton of money into content
I should just push it
and even if I don't get
an email or nothing?
- That's right, 'cause
brand leads to opportunity.
You know, when you're doing
funnels to landing pages
to get leads, you're
in the sales business.
I think you need to add
some marketing and branding.
I didn't have the luxury
of living in this world
that you guys live in.
There weren't people like me talking about
emotional intelligence around business.
You know, this was, and
so I'm excited, you know,
when that young man's like, "You really,"
like when I hear that,
"I've been watching you for three years,
"you really changed my mindset."
It's so powerful, it's so powerful.
I sit there and when I
hear that I'm like, man.
Hey, you know it's funny, I
don't even feel like I'm myself
I'm like almost watching the conversation
and I'm like "Wow, the world is so crazy,"
like we can all, you guys
already both feeling it as well
and so it's just crazy to
be able to impact somebody
and I also know what I'm
putting in the system.
I'm putting a very important
thing into the system,
I think, selfishly, because
I'm winning in business,
I'm an alpha male, and most alpha males
that are winning in
business are talking about
very different things
than I'm talking about.
And I think it's an important
balance to the conversation.
Leaving money on the table,
patience, doing the right thing,
gratitude, empathy, like all
this stuff that, you know
unfortunately for the last 50 years
alpha business men were talking about
alpha business men stuff,
but deeply and secretly
were very unhappy and very broken.
And I don't know, that's
just not interesting to me.
I don't wanna teach people
how to make a million dollars
but then do drugs and
alcohol and be in depression.
What's the point?
- Yes, it's about the purpose.
- Yeah, and you know what's funny?
I'm very into like, winning, and building,
and this is not for me like,
I'm not looking to be a monk
or a healing coach, or
live in that mountain
and have people come
and talk to me about it,
I just think it's true.
I think you can build a
more successful business
if you're actually happy.
(gentle music)